okay so first reactions you win big
brother Canada the show that you've
loved for your whole life
how are you feeling um it's hard to put
into words I'm I'm on cloud nine for
sure I think it's gonna take some time
for it to sink in but I envision that
moment of me walking out with all the
you know what are they called all the
things that come out all the confetti
there we go and it was a reality it was
a reality about an hour ago and it's
just it's unreal it's everything I
wanted more it's so special
we had a for the first time ever we had
two girls in the final two which was
really really fun we did get a little
heated and crazy in there but you know
it's unreal how didn't believe sunk in
yet they'll tell you that what is it
like being in front of the jury
essentially fighting for your life
nerve-racking like I said I was a
confident person I thought I had no
problem talking to you know anybody but
oh it's crazy because you know you have
like 30 seconds to just kind of plead
your case and tell them what you did
this entire game and for me it was
really difficult because my game was
centered around a lot of my you know
social skills a lot of moves that I made
behind closed doors and it's so much of
I didn't even get to say in that you
know speech and I think that once the
players watch the show by thing you
break oh wow she was behind that move I
had no idea because when you have 30
seconds you you can't even think of what
you were Hurst like I rehearse for to
myself for like 24 hours prior and I
didn't say any of those things because
in the moment you're just blurting
things out you just like give me your
phone this is all I have and so it was a
lot more difficult for me because a lot
of my moves were behind closed doors and
they needed a lot of explaining whereas
I think like kahler-jex moves were like
calm winds they taking out people and so
it was a lot more apparent than mine and
so that's one that definitely scared me
with the speeches a six to one vote in
your favor were there any surprises this
evening
um I think walking into tonight I really
was not sure if I wasn't beginning al
your lives phone I really really didn't
feel like it
I kind of imagined in my head that if I
was going up against Kayla I would
probably get Johnny Ryan Mattie and will
but I was kind of thinking in Micah for
three because when Ali walked out Oh
man she was so bitter same with Liv she
didn't want to talk with me and so I
just I I kind of thought it was gonna be
Leah for three five two best case
scenario but after I talked to Ali and
heard her question I realized that she
wasn't even for the best player and that
was my chance to sway her vote she
wasn't going to be bitter and I really
really appreciated that that was
something that I loved about the story
they were not bitter at all and um you
know that was my chance to sway her vote
and I did I think after talking with
them I feel like hey this might be a 5-1
but beforehand not at all I thought best
case scenario for three maybe five two
now two ladies in the finale obviously
history for Big Brother for Big Brother
Canada is that something that you saw
and and when you could see that this was
taking shape is it like yes this is my
season I'm gonna make history that's
what people didn't remember me for yeah
for sure it definitely plays into it I
will be honest with you though you when
you are in that spot of who you want
next to you a lot of it is the game
and the love it is like okay who do I
have a better chance against but it
definitely factored in that I was
getting you know I was gonna be making
history that this was like the gear for
women there were so many movements based
on that and I felt really honored that I
got to you know make a move that was
good for my game but also made history
in this way and it was awesome it felt
very empowering I'm not gonna lie it was
good what do you think your family and
friends are gonna think about the game
the way you played and the win I'm not
sure about my family because they don't
watch the show I don't know about them
but I know that my friends are really
really amazing supportive supportive
people and they always have you know
reassured me they're like you're special
you're so smart you have this and that
and I feel like maybe they go
told-you-so cuz they always were they
always told me like if you ever been on
that show you would win like you could
work your way through that house you
could win comps when you want to say if
you're like my friends are gonna be
supportive as always um I don't know I
think they might make fun of me for how
much I cried I was definitely very
emotional this season way more emotional
than I thought was going to be I
remember when we talked before going and
I was like I might be a savage like I
didn't come here to make friends and
every Thursday I would just be bawling
my eyes
so I don't know I'm hoping that they're
proud of the game I played I stayed true
to myself not one second did I fake me
somebody else I I was at just as goofy
as I am with my friends over here and I
didn't care that Canada was watching and
I was genuine I didn't try to fake me
you know fake somebody else and I'm
hoping that I came across I'm hoping
that Canada's you know happy with the
game I played no I mean you took the
game made history bringing home a
hundred thousand dollars I mean your
family's got to be they must be proud of
you at the end of all this I hope so I
mean again like they've never watched a
show they were like what is a big
brother what do you mean I'm like um
every time you thought I was studying
for exams yeah I was sitting there
watching live feeds and this is what my
life has been about for like god knows
how many years I'm sure they are I'm
sure they are I I couldn't imagine how
you wouldn't be honestly like I feel
like I accomplished something good and I
hope I made them proud at the end of the
day I really do now you know obviously
you got that six to one vote overcoming
any sort of bitter feelings that people
may have had when you step out of the
house and you guys are happy you just
had this big thing you're partying
together taking photos together
are there any residual feelings that
people have or is the game over and it's
all cool now I honestly couldn't talk
about other seasons I'm not sure how
other seasons worked but I know from my
end I genuinely want to hang out with
every single one of these people and
again that's not a mindset I had coming
into this house I didn't care I was like
who cares who's in there with me
I wonder $100,000 but you know it's just
I love these people like there's four of
us from Vancouver I cannot wait to see
them after the house and to me the one
person that was gonna be most bitter to
me towards me was gonna be Allie and she
showed that she wasn't and so I feel
like everyone's gonna be getting over
that I think the game is over now and I
think that we're just gonna go back to
being normal and just you know hang out
and have a good time hopefully I don't
know and you're gonna be buying all the
lunches oh yeah it's on me it's on me
I'm ballin it's on me